Mind Your Decisions, Presh Talwalkar here.
The American Invitational Mathematics Examination, or AIME for short, is a qualifying test in America for the International Mathematical Olympiad. It's a 3-hour test that includes 15 questions, and
calculators are not allowed.
Every answer is a whole number from 0 to 999
inclusive. In this video, we'll cover problem 7 from the 1984 exam:
"The function f is defined on the integers and
satisfies f(n)=n-3 if n ⩾ 1000, and
it's equal to f(f(n+5)) if n < 1000.
The question is: what is f(84)?
I thank Henry from the Philippines for suggesting this problem.
Pause the video if you'd like to give it a try, and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
So if you're like me, you try to solve this problem by directly calculating f(84).
Since 84 < 1000, this is equal to f(f(89)).
Since 89 < 1,000, this is equal to f(f(f(94))).
If you try working this direction a little further, it feels like you're trying to open a Russian doll:
each time you're trying to simplify the problem, you end up with a copy of the problem, and
it doesn't seem to be getting any simpler. It just seems to be getting more and more nested and,
eventually, you're not getting anywhere
So sometimes, when you try and solve a problem, you end up with a dead-end but don't despair.
Try another approach.
Rather than directly trying to calculate f(84), let's try working from the other direction.
Let's try calculating for values around 1,000. What is f(999)?
By definition, this is equal to f(f(1004)).
Now, by definition, f(1004) is equal to n-3, which is 1001.
Now, we apply the definition once more , and we get the answer of 998.
We'll do a similar thing to calculate f(998).
We applied the definition of f(n), and we end up with 997.
Let's try working out a few more examples. What's f(997)?
While we work through the definition of f(n), we get to f(999).
Luckily, we've just calculated that this is equal to 998
We can do a similar calculation for f(996),
where we get to f(998), and this is equal to 997.
Let's calculate a few more: what's f(995)? We work through the definition and we get to f(997), which is equal to 988.
f(994) will be equal to f(f(999)), or will be equal to f(998), and that's equal to 997.
So we see a pattern emerging:
for values less than
1,000, f(odd number) = 998,
998, and f(even number) = 997.
You can prove this by induction.
Ultimately, we get that f(84), since 84 is an even number, will be equal to
997, and that's our answer.
Now, I just want to do a little extension for fun.
This problem can actually be solved very elegantly and very simply using computer code.
Now, I know it's a problem from a 1984 exam, but we can actually use modern computer code, like Python, to solve this very quickly.
So we wanted to find a function doll(n).
If n is >= 1000, we want to get the value of n-3.
Otherwise, we want to get the value of f(f(n+5)).
This will be written as return doll(doll(n+5)),and this is something pretty interesting.
We're defining the function doll in terms of the function doll!
This is an example of recursion, and we'll use it to solve this problem now
You just type in this code, and then type in print(str(doll(84))), and you'll get the answer of 997 instantly!
it's amazing that Python can solve this problem so quickly, and all you need to do is type in the definition of this problem.
So this is a great problem from a 1984 test, and the problem can illustrate the power of computer code!
Thanks for being the best subscribers on YouTube, thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.
"Success consists of going from failure to failure without loss of enthusiasm." - Winston Churchhill